ne cuisinent et pas l'hibiscus qui
pousse dans votre jardin n'est pas
comestible
contrairement à sept autres variétés
cultivées dans les régions tropicales
avant moi je pensais juste que ça
existait en afrique matt est originaire
du bénin la bosse plante est appelée by
sa et ce sont les calices et non les
pétales de la fleur qui sont séchées
pour ensuite être infuse et transformées
en poudre en faisant mes recherches le
produit je me suis rendu compte que ça
existe dans beaucoup plus de régions que
ça en amérique latine on la surnomme la
fleur de jamais en egypte c'est karkadé
en asie du sud est
rosen je me suis dit waouh c'est un
produit qui est consommé dans plusieurs
pays du monde et j'ai envie de le faire
ressortir comme un produit qui réunit
les gens qui la jeune entrepreneur s'est
lancé dans la production de jus
d'hibiscus c'est vraiment commenter en
fait on le fait infuser puis après on
mélange qu'on a envie de mélanger dans
mes du sud puis on fait refroidir
biologique mais la boisson de tous les
jours titre
dans plusieurs pays africains des
vendeuses vente ces boissons du marché
sont toujours des lycéens dans des
sachets congelés qui s'est sucré s'est
classé des comme il fait chaud pays tout
ça il ya un vainqueur
on y va bien on prenne acte était
vraiment c'est vraiment un rituel au
rituel qui tu m'as tu aimerais bien des
plantes et ici il ya des gens qui quand
et le bois ils vont goûter le raisin y
en a qui vont goûter des baies y en a
qui vont goûter des ponts konaté
vraiment chacun fils un peu différent
que d'être en bois est un peu la
nouvelle 15% quand même des personnes
qui ne goûte son kop world je
m'attendais pas south et rafraîchissant
et à chaque fois je me dis rien
[Rires]
les arômes floraux ont la cote ces
temps-ci et l'hibiscus gagne en
popularité
présent dans les tisanes et dans les
confitures ils se pointent aussi dans
les glaces et comme bout de chats bière
il même dans le jean
ça fait un an maintenant qu'il est sur
le marché on est en rupture de stock
on peine à produire et jean-françois
pied auraient et le créateur de ces
jeans
là on va y goûter à l'étape pour être
capable vraiment de faire tout percevoir
des notes la semaine ce prix canneberge
si vous sentez comme une foule vous
allez sentir un petit peu le lait grelet
sur est un peu du knb de la canebière en
fait l'origine je voulais faire un jean
un peu boréale avec des herbes et des
épices du québec
le premier ingrédient côté que l'on
voulait travailler c'était le thé du
labrador
puis après ça on a changé de caisse
qu'il faut être complémentaire au 10
novembre
puis ils disent que c est ressorti tout
à fait de floral pour vient vraiment de
son embauche connu jadis quand même le
fait de travailler il ya beaucoup de
savoir qui est très très très savoureux
les savants sont intenses mais quand tu
crées un cocktail se mettre en valeur
ariane côté la voie publique selon moi
j'adore faire des classiques pour
réinventer des classiques je suis parti
un peu du tome collines qui est un kit
un drink de base à base de ginseng est
une limonade gêne un petit peu j'ai lu
marisa avec le cassis
qui est une bête qui allait vraiment
bien avec les excuses sa fonderie qui
suit pas rafraîchissant plus vraiment
histoire
l'hibiscus se tailler une place aussi
dans le coeur de nos chefs cuisiniers je
les découvre quand j'étais au japon il y
avait un dessin hibiscus j'ai beaucoup
aimé la couleur la présentation à peu
près ça le goût floral aurait pu un peu
acidulées c'est plus une effusion de
vous faire patienter pour le réduire
ça fait une chose c'est ça qui donne
c'est ce qui arrive mais là c'est
vraiment motivant cette sauce parfume
bien ce canard cuit sur un barbecue
japonais étonnant comme une vraie
réussite et le chef nous propose aussi
une version glacée de l'hibiscus 18 avec
un petite artère de fraises puis gravité
des biscuits caviar de vaccins pia qui
l'idée l'hibiscus sur une souris nuit'
rose est venu comme un jeu la mairie
avec encore un côté marin ça marche très
bien sans en granit et sauce jus et même
pour aromatiser une alcool cette plante
tropicale semble bien vouloir élire
domicile dans le palais
[Musique]